so fluorine is the most reactive element
it's meant to be pale green but I've
never actually seen it and I never smelt
it either because if it gets out and I
have been in a room where there's been
the small flooring leak it reacts with
the water in your nose to make hydrogen
fluoride which smells dreadful hydrogen
fluoride is quite an interesting
compound because it is fantastically
reactive and corrosive it will dissolve
up human flesh when I read my
four-year-old son the story of Wizard of
Oz and Dorothy pause a bucket of water
over the Wicked Witch Simon asked was
there HF in the water fluorine is very
reactive but sometimes you have to use
very special procedures to get it to
react properly I've got a piece of
apparatus just in here in my cupboard
this is a an unique piece of apparatus
which was used for making oxides of
fluorine Oh 2 F 2 where fluorine was
passed and oxygen was passed went down
one side and across here you put a very
high voltage and the electric voltage
dissociated the molecules oxygen reacted
with and the fluorine reacted and the
whole of this vessel was immersed in
liquid nitrogen which allowed the
product o to f2 to freeze on the outside
on the outside walls of the vessel